[Musique]
mais tout le monde tu as vu squeeze un
nouveau studio pas dû tourner chez moi
comment allez vous et vous est ce que ça
va nous voilà réunis pour une nouvelle
vidéo tout d'abord je propose une trêve
capillaire pendant toute la durée du
confinement n'a pas le droit de se
moquer des cheveux des gens ça m'arrange
grandes banques
évidemment ça résonne pas mal j'en suis
j'en suis désolé tout d'abord et
l'activité qu'on va faire n'est pas
folle
ça fait beaucoup de mauvaises nouvelles
d'un coup mais au moins c'est honnête
tout d'avoir un peu de contexte juste
avant le confinement je suis allé
récupérer plein de matos à mon bureau
pour le ramener chez moi pour pouvoir
tourner par exemple à cette vidéo est
typiquement une faille du matos pourquoi
retourner genre de truc et je me suis
dit [ __ ] mais comment je vais faire
des activités manuelles si je peux pas
commandé de matos en fait pour faire la
poterie commandait le truc qui permet de
faire de la poterie et j'achetais de
l'argile pour faire de la sculpture de
ballons mais j'ai acheté des ballons etc
bref vous avez compris à chaque fois que
j'ai une activité manuelle je passe une
bonne commande sur internet où je vais
en magasin mais là ça c'est charles j'ai
donc fais avec ce que j'avais sous la
main et en fait en partant du studio je
me suis aperçu que une marque m'avait
envoyé un carton avec eux dans un truc
qui correspond à une activité manuelle
et ce quelque chose attention accrochez
vous bien c'est de la pâte à modeler
c'est bon ou pas bon alors je sais ce
que vous pensez et on pense tous pareils
mais vous savez on fait avec ce qu'on a
rigolez pas j'avais vraiment envie
tourner le dos aux activités manuelles
ce qu'on a fait beaucoup de vidéo là sur
le pc récemment en vidéo aurait extrait
et c'est de ce fait du bien un p'tit
deux activités manuelles avant de
tourner et j'ai donc checker le guen de
la pâte à modeler et bien vous savez
quoi
il ya des trucs assez cool affaires en
pâte à modeler faut pas prendre de recul
surtout quand vous regardez cette vidéo
ne prenez pas de recul tout d'abord il y
en aurait que j'ai comprise très
rapidement vous pouvez penser à
n'importe quel objet il ya un an plus
tôt pour faire 7 objets en pâte à
modeler sur youtube pour c'est n'importe
quoi
vas-y n'importe quoi là à tout ce dont
vous avez envie puisqu'on est confiné un
big mac
ok il ya des vrais trucs style affaires
et compris des petits animaux c'est ce
qu'on va faire bisquer de vidéos mhz à
se trouver sur youtube qu'ils je vais
rien comprendre
j'arrive néanmoins de vol alors je
suppose qu'ils ont fait ça bien et que
la couleur du bouchon c'est la couleur
de la pâte qui se trouve à l'intérieur
j'ose espérer
j'avais oublié cette odeur
elle me rappelle mon enfance or la
texture oh ça va être dur ça n'a rien de
facile la pâte à modeler souvenez vous
un nom faisait juste des boules
nous les to b cette page ou alors tout
d'abord les amis on va commencer par
faire un petit un petit animal mignon a
qu'à la musique yves aux lois avec un
ukulélé
c'est fort excusez moi si je ne souris
pas genre ce sera moins bien alors juste
les bruitages c'est vraiment le bruit
d'un corps qui est en train d'être
décapités enfin je suis désolé mais
peut-être
revoyez vos bruitages après bon ça sent
tellement bon mec la pâte à modeler la
vérité c'est que j'aurais fait même sens
le confinement mais que j'aurais jamais
assumé là c'est l'excusé parfaite alors
j'ai une boule et comment elle a fait le
trou au milieu
ah oui à décapiter un mec c'est vrai hop
là ça c'est fait mais c'est quoi ces
bruits mais elle écrasait qui ont tout
cela et ensuite aux messieurs dames je
vous présente un accessoire normes qui
se souvient de sa c'est l'épée pour
piquer les petits fours si fort qu'on ne
mange plus puisqu'on ne se rassemblent
le plus pur sur la fin
alors j'ai fait deux gros trou dans le
pif attention on assemble les deux
parties et c'est steve et la suite ils
sont trop bien hoa les huées sont
géniaux
et je suis vraiment heureux [ __ ] mais
c'est un peu ça à chaque fois c'est
vraiment sympa les tout manuel gones ont
fait la langue est mais [ __ ] c'est
hyper réussi 0 blague
pour faire quoi une boule à préfère un
cône au ca se forment tous sont nombreux
et de une
excusez-moi j'ai pris du recul sur ce
qui se passait pendant un instant cg10
faut pas vraiment fait pas à b ok la
suite à la
[Musique]
il est horrible mais pourquoi tu me l'a
pas dit avant ce cochon bas aucune âme
aucune âme vous m'entendez c'est quoi
les groupes assez les doigts on en est
là dans le détail où vous les doigts
mais attends mais c'était pas des doigts
ou des orteils ce qui s'appelle
clairement des tumeurs je suis désolé
moi j'ai eu un même sac quand j'étais
plus jeune qui est mort d'une tumeur
c'était ça allait huit petites boules
on va lui mettre ces tumeurs et monsieur
cauchois ces tumeurs ou quoi la suite la
queue mais oui la queue du cochon hu
alors shore tu as raison
j'ai eu une belle queue de cochon là ok
je prends très au sérieux cette que là
elle est pas mal
[Musique]
les amis je crois que monsieur cochon
est terminée tout va bien tout va bien
c'est qu'une jambe même si elle couche
et voilà un temps des devoirs le
personnage d'après tout aussi connues
que monsieur cochon monsieur cheval je
n'ai pas de grille j'ai du gris
attendait c'est grimm c rose est
daltonien très grave c'est très bien ok
on allait kaboul en fait le choix j'ai
envie de réussir il estimé il perde 3,16
salles de toy story est d'ailleurs très
connu ça ne fait pas ce bruit arrêté
c'est faux ok donc la fois pillée juste
l'arrière ça fasse des sabots ça marche
en plus à elle le pire c'est que ça
marche ça bosse effet les jambes au plus
tard dès que j'ouvre pour en vrai ça me
fait plaisir de faire un truc manuel en
cette période de confinement en vrai de
vrai je crois je me suis habitué à faire
des vidéos activités manuelles et du
coup ça me fait du bien
ok pour faire un come [ __ ] elle et ben
c'est une belle jambe
si elle veut bien aller bien loin
ok la suite alors là le corps mais les
jambes ne vont jamais tenir le corps est
tellement fatsah ne résistera pas à
tenter non j'ai pas la même couleur au
nord ces parages et aux caisses par as
pas je lui fais un corps d'une couleur
différente ce pas on peut dire qu'il a
un peu tu vois genre lui il est pas
resté confiné il est allé se régaler au
soleil lui et du coup il a vachement
bronze
il en train de subir son propre poids
ces terribles pendant que vous vivez en
1 g lui il est en 2g
c'est bon c'est bien c'est merci superbe
et un superbe là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ton [ __ ] je m'étonne qui a déjà passé
2 mois je m'en vais
[Musique]
il est un peu moins bon mais c'est parce
que j'ai pas eu le temps de faire le
pelage rdi la jane fracture l'a donc si
je rajoute en plus du poids en faisant
les cheveux c'est mort mais il est pas
mal
alors là l'ultime challenge suis là je
vous jure je veux pas le rater parce que
si je leur a pas je vais le garder genre
messieurs dames
nous allons nous attaquer à la
production d'un pikachu en pâte à
modeler lg à tous aujourd'hui je vous
retrouve pas bah voilà quelqu'un qui
parle français en plus
abonnez vous à 8 h 8 elle est presque au
100 mille abonnés allez allez on
s'abonne en masse cette fois ci ce sera
pikachu là il est trop bien il est trop
bien je veux trop le réussir pour ce
tuto vous aurez besoin d'eux jaune
vous allez faire un bout d'un jaune
assez gros et assez épais et en fait
vous allez voilà l'un curve est très
difficile d'expliquer cette étape d'un
gâteau comprendre et elle a beaucoup
travaillé
ok si ce trailer perfectionner un peu la
chose vous y rendre avec toi je suis
dingue est ensuite on va venir séparer
les deux jambes de pikachu donc pour
cela vous prenez votre cure dents et
vous allez en fait
or on l'est pour faire une démarcation
entre les deux jambes et vous voyez
pikachu il a un peu des jeux mais si on
peut appeler ça des gens mais à son
assez courtois
par contre tu es venu parler pikachu
tout de suite désabonnez vous qu'ils
soient abonnés aux quais bas juste ça
c'est très dur en fait je peux commencer
à faire je pense la démarcation
ok j'ai fait ses jambes
il tient pas debout ce normal sont pas
finis ensuite c'est quoi vous prenez une
poule jaune et ensuite c'est une étape
primordiale
il faut former en fait le petit nez de
pikachu vous roulez et en fait ça va
creuser dans votre pool pour donner du
roller unis donc là vous voyez que ça
commence à apparaître
wam était trop forte [ __ ] moi j'ai pas
une glace magnum pourrit la vie
[Musique]
aucune patience en cette matière n'a
fait ces deux petites jambes elles sont
à peu près bien quand il est bien il est
bien ok ensuite la tête
écoutez le truc du nez je crois avoir
réussi un c'est pas mal hein franchement
je suis content ensuite on va venir
faire les oreilles vous fait un bout
d'un jaune et vous allez affiner les
extrémités et le but c'est de couper au
milieu de ce bout d'un prêt à faire la
même chose donc un boudin noir cette
fois ci pour les assemblées ensuite avec
les boudins jaune mais attends c'est pas
des conneries en fait ça marche et
ensuite tout cas attention moment ça va
j'ai la tête en vrai ça marche bien à ce
qu'elle dira écoutez là c'est un conseil
si vous voulez la suite
ensuite on va venir faire les yeux vous
faites de boue noire comme ça allait
aplatir et vous allez mettre un petit
bout de film ou blanches
ensuite vous les disposer sur le visage
précédemment réalisé elle est trop forte
que 90% de son côté mignon se joue dans
les yeux avec ce titre x2 du truc blanc
dans l'oeil
son sac mon cheval avait l'air un peu
con d pourquoi on dirait sonic mais
avant qu'il refasse un beau gosse en ce
temps à venir faire les bras donc vous
faites un boudin jaune que vous avez
tout simplement coupé en deux il faut
les orienter légèrement vers l'intérieur
donc voyez très léger au casting et on
va s'occuper de la fameuse que de
pikachu en forme d'éclair wassa sacré en
fait tu prenais tout simplement un
modèle sur internet et vous tracez
exactement la même forme que la partie
marron que de pikachu vous faites la
même chose mais cette fois ci avec la
partie jaune de la cup puisqu'elle joue
ensuite avec un cure dent alors vous
allez tout simplement étirer la partie
marron sur la partie jaune comment sais
tu dois tenir on ne peut pas tenir
ensuite vous allez faire cuire votre cul
en fout allez il aura pas de que le mien
[Musique]
c'est la dernière étape mardi la tête
non c'est non
[Musique]
mais il est carré mais qu il a été en
configurant pendant un an
ouah c'est dire que tout ce que
j'imaginais bon c'est pas parce que des
enfants âgés de moins de deux ans joue
avec que c'est facile
ah oui c'est ça la morale en fait c'est
comme d'hab c'est un truc qui est
minutieux du coup faut être patient y
père attentionné hyper comme on dit
pointilleux voilà c'est le mot recherché
et c'est tout ce que je suis pas en
témoignent ces deux personnages j'espère
tout de même vous aurez passé un beau
moins que vous aurez diverti franchement
si vous avez de la pâte à modeler chez
vous n'allez pas en acheter évidemment
c'est une confinement si vous avez de la
pâte à modeler qui traînent chez vous
j'aimerais bien viser voir après chaque
fois je dis ça à chaque fois vous
m'envoyer des trucs extraordinaires on
vous avait fait que moi mais en 24 x
mieux ça m'énerve mais j'ai quand même
pris du plaisir même si le résultat est
mauvais et je pense que c'est comme
toujours de la pratique comme d'hab
voilà voilà j'espère que la vidéo vous a
plu ah désolé pour la queue du coup
c'est vrai que c'est honteux un pikachu
sens que mes fallait faire cuire et où
est la flemme je vous dis à bientôt une
prochaine vidéo je sais pas si je
trouverais a de quoi faire une autre
vidéo activités manuelles probablement
portez vous bien et je peux faire des
sorties forte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]